- [Interviewer] All right, Rose
Rose, where'd you grow up?
Where you from originally?
- [Rose] Richmond, California.
- [Interviewer] And you grew
up with both your parents?
- Kinda, sorta, not really.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood,
you had both parents?
- No, just my father.
- [Interviewer] Just dad?
What happened to mom?
- It doesn't matter.
- [Interviewer] How was,
how was your childhood?
- It was rough,
confusing,
tiresome.
Like anybody else's.
- [Interviewer] No
abuse? Nothing traumatic?
- Nothing too traumatic, no.
Nothing that the regular
child doesn't go through.
- [Interviewer] So, at
what point did you kind
of, your sexuality become aware to you?
- It's not my sexuality.
It's more like,
I don't think
of it as my sexual orientation.
It's my gender.
And who I am as a person.
I, what I'm doing right now,
when you're transitioning
you're basically trying to
mirror the person that
you are in the inside,
on the outside.
Cause I definitely don't match the outside
of my exterior.
Inside feels,
I feel different.
I feel like, I dunno, I
just can't explain it.
It's something, I mean I
would love to explain it
to the world but it's just something that
I'm not ready for yet.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And how long, how long have you
- Been transitioning?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- I've been transgender my whole life.
I've been transitioning for about,
10 years,
close to it.
- [Interviewer] And when
you made that transition, as
as you're making this transition
do you lose friends or do you find
- I lost a lot of friends.
I lost a lot of family.
I lost a lot of fake friends.
I lost,
I didn't really lose anything.
If you really think about it,
- Yeah I was gonna say
I didn't lose 'em , I just
- [Interviewer] So the
friends that you held on to
- Oh, the friends that I yeah,
I've had some really good support systems,
- That's great
- really good support systems
- [Interviewer] That's nice to hear.
So you're here in the
Tenderloin, San Francisco.
What do you, what are
you doing for money now?
- Well I
- Dress like that.
- Well, dress like this,
you know, this is, don't categorize me
but you know, I'm just free.
I'm a free spirit.
Like I don't care what people think.
They can look at me.
They can stare at me.
They can take pictures, all they want.
I just feel like I'm a human
being that deserves to live
and deserves to be treated
with respect and equality,
just as well as everyone else.
- [Interviewer] Do you get
a hard time, sometimes?
- I do. Very much.
- what kind of stuff?
- I'll be walking down the street
and somebody would be like
that's a boy or that's a man.
And I'm glad that they
can understand that.
I'm glad that they could see that.
But a regular man usually
doesn't pay attention to us
unless that's what he's attracted to.
So a grown man usually
keeps his mouth shut
and minds his own business,
worried about him and his wife
and his kids.
Instead of worrying about another man
or another transgender.
- [Interviewer] The
ones who get upset by it
are the ones who
- Yeah, who really want it.
And who secretly want to
take me around the corner
Who do, usually it's amazing.
I'll be walking down the
street and out of a whole group
of five guys, there'll
be two guys to sit there
and be talking shit about me and really
the other guys aren't saying nothing.
They're just looking
because they're noticing
what he's saying,
- You're fun to look at
- Right.
Or whatever the case may be.
And I mean, I've been
in situation where there was
a transgender woman who was
I don't want to use the word
cocky, but she was very hard.
And at the beginning of her transition
and they were making fun
of her and the guy said
can you believe that's a tranny?
And I said, you might want to
be careful who you're talking
to because you never know
what you're walking into
in the city.
You know you never know
what kind of person
you're gonna meet.
And he clearly just disrespected me
because I'm transgender too.
And I stand with her.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
It's an interesting
reaction that people have.
Isn't it?
So are drugs a part of
the picture for you?
- They were.
- There's a lot of drugs in
this neighborhood.
- There's a lot of drugs
in this neighborhood.
You have to be very careful what you do.
You have to be very
careful who you do it with.
All kinds of stuff. You
just gotta be careful.
- [Interviewer] What did
you play around with?
- Only like, ecstasy, meth
that's about it.
Marijuana is not a drug.
Okay. I smoke it every day.
Cause it calms me down.
It helps with my anxiety.
I haven't really tried too many drugs.
- [Interviewer] You haven't?
- I haven't.
- [Interviewer] Is there
something about this lifestyle
that kind of
you find yourself drawn to?
You know, you're basically
living, where do you live?
Are you on the street?
- No, I live on Hyde street.
- [Interviewer] So you
have an apartment, or?
- I have something like that. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Hotel?
- It's a hotel that's
turned into apartments.
- [Interviewer] Right. But
being in this neighborhood and
- It's a struggle.
It's a struggle.
It's a big struggle.
I walk out my house every
day to being threatened
laughed at, humiliated.
And after a while your skin gets so thick
that you just forget about it.
You stop hearing people,
you stop giving a fuck.
Excuse my language.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. No,
but I think you become
like a stronger
- I'm unapologetically trans.
Does that make sense?
I'm not gonna apologize for anything.
I'm not gonna stop being me
for nothing in the world.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned, in your life.
- Mind your business,
for me, mind my business.
- [Interviewer] And this was something
you were born with right?
- What?
- Being trans.
- Yes. My parents knew as a young age.
- [Interviewer] And your
parents were cool with it?
- Not every parent wants their
child to go through that.
- You're dad?
- It's not because of who
you're gonna be.
It's because of what
you're gonna go through.
And I didn't understand
that at a young age
and they were trying to force
me to be someone I wasn't
and look what happened.
Because they didn't fully accept me.
And because they couldn't
accept me and support me
I just didn't give a fuck what they said.
- [Interviewer] What kind of crazy stuff.
I mean, what's the most
extreme thing you've seen here
in the Tenderloin?
Lots of violence?
Lots of crazy stuff right?
- I've seen the craziest thing
was someone dying
that I think was, and
bringing him back to life.
Me and my friend was very extreme.
I was walking down the street one day
and some lady just gave me, a Narcan?
and I didn't really know what it was.
But since at the time I was
doing meth, I was like, okay
well maybe I should keep it
because there was fentanyl going around.
And one of my friends, I'm
not gonna use any names
but one of my friend's husband
had overdosed in an alley.
And my hotel room was right
there above this alley.
So like I heard the screaming
and the yelling and my friend
was running down the hall.
I mean running down the street, screaming
like someone call the
cops, somebody call 911.
And like, all I can remember was
that that lady gave me a Narcan.
So I grabbed the Narcan
went downstairs and put it in his nose.
And he went from purple
to like pale color.
So he was breathing.
It was pretty crazy.
But if it was, if I didn't do that
he would be dead right now.
- [Interviewer] Hmm.
Do you find getting a
straight job difficult
with your identity?
- A straight job?
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
working at a department store
or working in an office,
something like that.
- [Rose] There's the
double sword for that.
I'm gonna have to say that, yes.
Society makes it very hard
for us to get jobs due
to the fact that we're trans
and everybody wants to
comment on our lifestyle
everybody wants to say something.
And me personally, I'm a, I
don't give a fuck type person.
So if I hear you say something
about me, 9 times out of 10
I'm gonna ask you if you wanna fight.
Or if, what is that any of your business?
You know what I mean?
Like, what is it in your business
What I am and what I'm doing with my life?
Does it have an effect on your life?
Cause if it does, you're
focused too hard on me.
Do you know what I mean?
But they make it very hard.
I had a job.
I had multiple, I had multiple jobs.
I worked for Denny's.
I worked for Metro.
I worked for the Sopaipilla
Factory in New Mexico.
I worked for TGIJP out
here in San Francisco.
That was the best job I've ever had.
That was the last job I had.
- [Interviewer] (indistinct)
I think, I think you're convincing enough
that you probably fool a lot of people.
- I don't want to fool anybody.
I just want to live my life
and have people accept me for who I am.
- [Interviewer] That's
great. That's very healthy.
And where do you see your
life going from here?
What do you wanna do?
- I don't know.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- I'm 25.
- [Interviewer] You're a kid?
- I'm a baby.
I'm younger than half these people.
- [Interviewer] Did you go to high school?
- I did.
- [Interviewer] And what
kind of kid were you
in high school?
- I was an okay kid.
- You're not yet
- I was trans.
- You were?
- In high school yes I was.
- [Interviewer] And how was that?
That must've been tough right?
Teenagers can be cruel.
- [Rose] I guess you can
say I could be cruel too.
(interviewer chuckles)
- You were tough?
- [Rose] I can hold my own.
- [Interviewer] Alright, Rose,
thank you so much for talking
with me.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] And good luck out there.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] All right.